[Music]
so if you really want to talk awesome
time to unwrap the presents on Gwyneth
Paltrow's lips now these are gift that
make you go oh my goodness no wonder the
latest goop pop-up store attracted an
English crowd Kate Hudson Demi Moore and
daughter Rumer Willis got their shop on
at Gwyneth's first-ever goop Gift Guide
pop-up shop it's very exciting we love
it dumi took home a teddy bear that does
yoga poses for 30 bucks a real steal
because the goop list is known for
over-the-top extravagance what's the
most expensive item here
well the LG styler was a gift in the
ridiculous but awesome guys it basically
is a dry cleaner at home so it saves the
food trips to the dry cleaner you put
something in under an hour it's done the
two thousand dollar dry cleaner may be
the most expensive item in the LA store
but online you can really splurge
there's an 80 $300 year which is
basically a tent a $2,500 razor or how
about some chocolate toothpaste for a
hundred twenty bucks who comes up with
this list so there are 600 products in
good gift and the 600 gifts are picked
up by Gwyneth and the good team and for
the person on your list who really wants
to live like Gwyneth there's the
infrared sauna price tag just shy of
2,300 bucks
I love the infrared sauna that has
changed my life
there's something for everyone in this
store so there's $10 stocking stuffers
too totally over-the-top finds like
caviar to go wait a minute
one more time caviar to go poop head to
go there are 30 gram tins or $100
you